I can't hear anything
Thank You everybody yet we do appear to
be live-streaming now I think you are
good afternoon counselors in staff in
anyone who is out in about this
afternoon on a beautiful ember coggle
day watching our meeting live wire the
platform of zoom Monday the 18th I have
an apology from councilor cricket who
has to shoot to pick up her little one
and we'll be back to the meeting so
apologies for lateness do I have any
other apologies okay thank you everybody
so no further apologies evening we're
happy to move that apology from
councillor cracker please raise your
hand thanks counselor efforts you can do
by councillor Munster and all those in
favor raise your right hand against
Kerry thank you very much everybody
moving to that interest register as you
know if there are any updates that I
required to please send those through to
the appropriate administrator and she
will ensure that those are updated for
us to adopt it any meeting moving to
item number four we have the minutes of
the Council of Committee meeting that
was held on Monday the 4th of may be
other than Twitter at 3:00 p.m. I have
someone if you're happy with those
minutes - please move those things
counter to the clerk's you can do by
Councillor Ludlow any questions or
discussion on those minutes great all
those in favor give me a wave dance
against carries thank you moving to item
number five of our agenda today which is
obviously the in committee minutes sorry
the minutes of Monday the 5th of May
2000 in 2018 a.m. and that was the
additional meeting that we had I'm happy
to move those minutes please
um pink can't cancel a bit or can I just
point out it should reach Tuesday the
5th of May okay thank you so much that
correction Tuesday the 5th of May at
10:00 a.m.
capsule um oh I see you have him set
change yeah I'm thinking cancel bit all
thank you anyone happen to see Kent
Thank You councillor Soper any
discussions of questions on there great
all those in favor please raise your
right hand welcome back councillor
cracker it was very quick
although I'm against carried welcome
back councillor cricket we've taken your
apology for lateness it was very very
quick and we are only up to item number
6 which is the city block consultation
and you'll have to excuse me I am
flicking between the same screen screen
it's a bit frustrating so I'm gonna go
into the report in a screen and to speak
to it if she is on the report thanks
Rhiannon thank you I'm chair Kira
councillors I will take the report as
read this report appends the
consultation document extra money for
city block which has been produced
following the conversation last week at
the workshop for your consideration I
just note one change in the report that
I'd like to make just to note that the
hearings planned for the week commencing
one 14th of June they'll just need to
happen then week later in order to
enable the agenda to be put out in time
so just like to correct that mistake in
my original report but otherwise I
present the consultation document and
propose consultation approach for your
consideration thank you
now questions of the report please I'm
gonna go with councillor amongst and
anyone else got questions I have some
myself so I'm gonna write my name down
anyone else on this subject
great Thank You councillor Monson it's
Tony
I just excuse any background noise and
we've got a builder here so I'm hoping
he's not going to be too noisy two
questions one is do we feel that the
consultation period is long enough I
know it's the standard length but I just
wonder given that everyone's going back
to being normal lives and readjusting to
that whether we need to allow some
flexibility here in terms of the length
of time and my second question is page
17 that sees there may be an impact on
the commencement or timing of other
projects in order to continue to manage
prudently when are we actually going to
discuss there and figure that stuff out
because I know we see that several times
including in the last lot of
consultation for this I'm just wondering
when we'll actually know what the impact
is and on what projects in for how long
listen to be talking about it a lot
thank you monks do you want me to answer
first and then past you Dave or do you
prefer to go ahead sorry I just wasn't
sure when I had to call from Tony at
that point so I didn't start speaking of
it cutting up partly there so if I've
got the call I'm happy to talk I think
it's at this stage that's it's not a
major issue for us to address but over
time we will okay so at the moment it's
it's a question counsellors for the LTP
as we've said through this we're going
to be pushing our data to higher levels
in combination of the levels that's
going to get to Plus very low interest
rates we're going to be going into a
reasonably risky time when you're fairly
close at least to your feet deep also
we've got that uncertainty that we've
talked about at the moment around rates
rises and if you recall the LTP was
premised on three point one percent at
three point one percent we don't run
into an issue but in our current
projections are that we're not likely to
be running at three point one percent
every direct rises from next three years
so it's a thing for us to factor enough
enough and a short answer through the
LTP and through the finance strategy as
to what we're going to do and how we're
going to manage it and there's a lot of
a lot of water to flow under the bridge
the bottom line is that we needed to
flag for people that there's not major
consequences in terms of rates in terms
of a difference for what we're talking
about in fact the bigger investment is
slightly cheaper than when we went out
for consultation on the smaller
investment because there are interest
rates have dropped so much but that does
though mean for us to create the
capacity going forward really for future
generations you don't want the next ten
years to gobble up the next 50 years of
borrowing capacity that's the critical
thing I think you Dave appreciate that
are you happy with it just give me a
flick yep cool um I've got some
questions as the anyone else who has
questions thanks counselor Clark I'm
just gonna ask for mine if it's okay and
I'm gonna have to flip between screen so
please forgive me my understanding
obviously is that counsel consulted
originally on the 20 plus the 5 plus the
5 and then we lost our investor I also
understand he left 4 million in the
project in I think this is probably for
more of a for the public which I think
it's important to keep them up to speed
we have a 16 million dollar gap and
we've applied for the government funding
by own ways of studi millennion grant
are we be there to wait until we get the
approval or they we find out from them
whether or not they are willing to
contribute to this particular project
aimed in the 16 million would then be
covered before we go to consultation and
if not can you just explain why Dave
it's the first one what one is one is
timing to be quite
honest so the decision really that's
required is is to enable the ICL to
start the process by signing the
contract and so before they sign the
contracts they need to know how much the
council is in for and while the
government may provide some funding for
us to be able to then put money and it
doesn't change the need still for us to
consult because the consultation basis
as to what we're going out for
consultation is that we always said that
if it was more than 230 million dollars
we put up last time around we would go
back to the community so to quite an
extent that's the purpose we're going
back to the community it's a very very
good point that you raise council
apologies chairman you're on mute I've
just realized that sorry my apologies
social distancing you're a mute all
these new fancy things won't even be
signing it and can you explain
obviously that 16 million dollar gay why
council was being asked to to foot that
bill rather than it being sort of shared
between the shareholders of the company
can you are you able to remember a beer
I think in secret me run through it
there was always that proposal that
would be three lots of 25 and and then
of course one dropped out did state that
they would leave formally and then let
left 21 the the other shareholder has
said no he's comfortable remaining for
the 25 million but not to put more in as
my understanding us as to where that's
at
and so that's why we are going out to
consult and of course we get to the 16
million additional requirement because
we've got the 25 plus the the five that
we already had in for contingency or
repurposing five million of the 30 and
if I couldn't a bit madam chair the
other investor mr. O'Donnell has made it
clear that he has an additional and
significant commitment in the
construction of the HW our town Stage
four so he is not in a position to share
the the shortfall of funding which is
why he's looking for it from Council
thanks clear MIT leads me to my second
to last question and it was around the
other obviously we we contribute to
stages 1 2 3 but the other stages around
the block have we got any indication
that they will continue as a result of
Kovich because obviously lots of
positions would have changed I suppose
to speed
we have confirmation from hwr that they
will proceed with stage four it stages
one two three are preceded with Stage
five is on hold because SI t results but
they should wait until august and have
another look at that
sorry Stage six my apologies SI t we're
looking at apartments on stage six and
stage five has not had a proposal for
progression for some time other than the
possibility of it being a storage
facility for the museum thanks clear in
just the last one sorry people but it's
important that we asked them they aside
take sorry the siege houston provincial
growth fund funding that had been
contributed to to this project that
still confirmed after covert I've got
the caulking stick I'll say yes it is I
can tell you that the documents from
Patriots of a nine and a half mil equity
the ten mil loan the documents have been
signed by the ICL shareholders and see
trance have also confirmed their funding
thank you I count some o'clock
I mean kept below council it has become
salami
sounds like Clanton account to the
cricket thank you yeah just a
clarification today so the given the
government infrastructure fund if it
does fund the city block as a funding
city for their investment or is it
funding the project I'm not sure what
distinction you're looking at in the mix
are they what do you mean by are they
funding city well I mean the city blocks
at a coalition of partners that are
investing is what we're seeking from the
government infrastructure fund is that
for if they're dovetailed to our
investment or is it to the wider project
because what I was going to lead up to
is if it was to the wider project and
not just to the council there sir
then would we need to
so if that money that came by way of
that fund actually removed our need for
the 16 million if it was going directly
in then no we wouldn't be investing more
I guess the the key element in the mix
of that counselors if we take a sort of
risk-based approach we would effectively
be allowing central government to delay
the commencement of the project until
they have resolved where they stand in
terms of their capital work program and
do we want to be in that position okay
so if what if for instance it's going
through the traps and we get some early
notification that you start potentially
in but but we're going to have to do
some other work and work up agreements
then effectively we'd be saying that we
would not start the project that the
contract documentation could not be
signed until that point was across then
we did have conversations with them with
hold Co and clear and I about this and
felt that really for the contract to be
able to be signed and for work to start
we really needed to start the
consultation now on the basis that
counsel was prepared to invest the
further money yes so just just a
follow-up question that day so if we
subsequently get some funding it comes
to us the ring is there potential that
could possibly cover any project overrun
given that Scott's sort of saying that
he won't invest any more than 25 in the
end of excellent and this is a the
question in terms of if we're successful
and getting any money in depth from from
the shovel-ready projects what it does
is it creates the capacity for the
council's debt cap to be able to support
other elements coming in so this could
for
rotate and overrun if that was to occur
but only to the extent probably that
we've already engaged with the public
about putting more money in there
because if the money comes to us then we
would mean be the investor that does
depend on the channel through which the
government puts in as well so just one
final reflection or comment I don't see
Megan here and our strategic look
forward on this project where we
affected in any potential overrun and I
listen carefully to what Brian Wood had
to say to us when he presented a few
months ago and he said most large
projects do over run about 10% and then
he countered that by saying none that
he'd been involved in the next you
overrun their projection which was nice
to hear that but I guess we do need to
have some against some contingency and
it seems to me from where we said that
if this project did overrun by five or
ten percent and given a Scott one and
Jake anymore and unlike the other
partners will come to them then we could
be consulting again couldn't we oh sorry
Dave my understanding is we have a
contingency in the air but I might be
wrong Dave can you elaborate a little
more you're quite right that was
actually what I was going to say account
so there is a contingency built into the
project and the other element of course
as they're going through the contracts
and so on will be written or in a way
the construction can occur within the
funds available therefore they will be
expected to value engineer to the extent
that they need to were to live with them
the funds available back thank you Dave
accounts my credit thank you can you
please confirm for me this if we do not
invest the 16 million or the public
redirect comes back and preferred option
is not to kiss the 16 million and the
project as it stands and how does
currently proposed without any
reconfiguration is it likely that we
would lose the gradual funding money in
the CTOs funding did you handle it clear
the answer to those years so it's likely
we will lose the additional funding
should we not continue with the project
in its entirety as it stands now a
musical question was based on help
councillor Clark's line of question I
should say the others room for a small
amount of flex yeah that bear in mind
that company is managing this and the
company has are comfortable that the the
rope that they are honest the correct
road subject with some minor
modifications as they go along the way
thank you your worship
still they are a pretty important
partner and we've got to make sure we do
everything possible to keep them on
track and keep them enthusiastic about
the investment they've made not just in
the track museum but of course and the
motorcycle maker as well they've
certainly proven their worth in can you
worship um just one other question
that's been brought as a result of
councillor crickets questioning and the
investors there was discussion prior
that we would be having discussion with
other alternative investors I'm if I
suppose I'm asking where that
conversation has got to if anywhere and
do we have any outcomes from those
discussions and then the final one is
now that we obviously are contributing a
great deal more than what was
anticipated in the beginning should the
community come back and be comfortable
with that does the shear holding
position change we're currently 14 on
the scene does that make a difference so
can I start at the last comment because
I want to make sure that counselors
understand that it's the debate or the
the arguments the views that the council
that the community puts forward and
counselors will be facing the need to
make a decision based on the weight of
their evidence and not just whether they
like it or they don't like it but the
points they make in it and I guess I
want to say that publicly because it is
an important part of consultation in
relation to the shareholding the
shareholding for numbersync will not
alter but the discussion around the
crime documentation is such that
counsels increased contribution would be
recognized as equity I think I'm right
with that term Dave if the if the entity
ICL was ever sold so it's a 49%
shareholding in terms of we are a
minority partner although a majority
funder and if it was sold that majority
of funding the majority equally would be
recognized and I'm sorry counsel a
little but you asked another question I
cannot now remember it the second
question was the investors but I now
have a follow on for Dave in relation to
your answer about risk in being a
majority contributor in a minority
shareholder on lead day to answer that
first and what was the question as
they're honest yeah the first one was
around the investors and if we had any
outcome second one was there's a
follow-on from clears answer what the
risk is to counsel with we are a
majority contributor a minority
shareholder for those of us who go and
watch
it's it's the thing that we had a lot of
conversation with whenever we were going
to be a minority contributor basically
where we're at risk to the extent of the
money that we invest and and in regards
to where we stand around that sort of
shareholding or otherwise it really
comes down to the ability to appoint
directors and the quality of the
directors we appoint there's not really
a significant difference between being
above 50% in below until you get up to
being over 75 because when you're at 75
then they're special resolutions and
things like that they can be blocked but
but actually apart from that is really
no major difference in terms of the risk
it really comes down to I guess the
extent to which we're going into this
with as a group of equals and there is a
possibility that the majority
shareholders could help both us that's
really not a significant issue given
that the other shareholders are
different parties and they're different
parties that don't have a common single
interest we've got the provincial growth
fund in there and we've got effectively
Cetus and not a tina shareholders but
certainly with a level of clout in terms
of what can happen around that so
they're not likely to vote specifically
against councils interests controlled
organisation the company will be covered
by company law which is effectively in
the interest of the company not in the
interest of an individual shareholder
thanks Dave
I think we've got a good feel councillor
Clark for the final and there's no one
else that wants to raise the question
thanks counselor Clark Oh in councillor
cricket thank you
just wanted to clarify with Dave because
I think I've asked this before some time
ago so if we're roughly an equal
shareholder with that with the other
partner and the company it will take a
small amount when when people say well
will we get their share 49% or 49.9%
share of the rent as it becomes
available I think your previously stated
in the past but that's a company
decision that they company as a whole
has it income which would be through
recovered rent and then it decides what
it was to do with it so it doesn't mean
that we've got what do you know in point
nine percent of it but it might be that
say they decide to pay off one of the
other business before distributing to a
positive cashflow later on and I think
that's that right I think the important
distinction is that we won't get any of
the Rings right if we get anything we
get a dividend and the dividend will be
declared by the directors of the company
I mean they're aware of the situation
they're at in regards to future cash
flows financial position thank you
mine's a little bit of a long-winded
walk around which is really for public
benefit more than anything because I
know that we've all collectively been
over this topic several times but one of
the questions that I'm hearing most
often is what is the reasoning for
continue with continuing with such a
large-scale retail or hospital
hospitality offering in a post covered
world and I know we've we've all talked
about like the risks and us losing the
funding if we don't and why there why it
needs to wash its face for - in terms of
funding in - how much at least that
we're going to get out of it but could
you just explain and potentially Dave
probably because he's all over the phone
it says why why it is yes sorry daughter
wanted a piece of brownie it's the
benefit of working from home what's the
reasoning and continuing with the
development is it stains
and why why would we carry on with this
project in the way shape or form that it
is currently when we're you know coming
out of a bit of a bit of a pandemic yeah
I guess that's the question that applies
to everything doesn't it because
actually I think one of the first points
I'd make as as we're not yet in a
postcode bird situation we're in the
middle of covered however that's a side
issue but it is really the element we
don't really know what the future holds
but we do have strategies around the
inner city and in our inner city
effectively having our inner city quite
what that will look like in five to ten
years time we'll we don't entirely know
now but one of the things that we
probably can reason that we will predict
is that in the new world newer buildings
are probably going to fare better than
old buildings which is effectively the
nature of our current stock who really
knows where you're going to go with with
retail and so on people have been
preaching doom and gloom around retail
for quite a long time
and likewise hospitality and it's really
hard to give an answer to that because
it is really the crux of the uncertainty
so so in the mix of it in the element of
uncertainty do you just sort of sit back
and wait and the unfortunate
consequences if you do just sit back and
wait then basically you get retrenchment
going on right throughout the economy
where everybody starts poking weights
and then the economy just goes and
effectively in two three four nobody
will do anything we just wait to see
what is going to happen you know there
is going to be a vacant block there and
something is going to need to be built I
think with the building having been
built you still have options as to what
goes into there
because you will actually have a
relatively new building it will need
probably to be some thoughts by the
directors which we know that they are
doing in terms of the the impacts that
this is happening of some of the detail
in the design as they had that might
work so that they can generate a little
bit more flexibility but it is a very
very difficult question because you
can't answer it with any certainty some
people will be sitting back and to be
quite honest that's the sort of answers
we're probably going to get from the
consultation some people will be coming
in saying don't do it others will be
saying well sure those needs to Cobert
come through and we need this to support
posts the key there there needing to
support the post covert environment
there's a lot of benefits that we have
outlined in the consultation document
you know like the expected increase in
Southlands GDP and more opportunities
and provisions for residents so just
really hope that we can get the the real
messages to why we're continuing with
this project and as it stands in that it
can wash its face are financially going
forward that's communicated in our
consultation you can create I'm just
gonna put these just because we have
spent a wee bit of time on this item but
that's great because he's been a lot of
questions asked and it's what we're here
to do so I can't look it on missed your
hand thank you
how many directors are going to be
appointed to ICL question number one
how many directors can we as the major
investor a point on our behalf those
first two questions the first issue is
that it's worth just taking a moment to
remind ourselves that this is not
council that is investing on us it is
hold code that is investing in this
at councils request so hold Co is
determining the directorships and at
this stage council actually requested
the cherub whole Kobe the director on
and the Kabul seats are limited and
there are currently two directors and
there are negotiations in place right at
the moment for a third and independent
director to join them thank you very
much the reason I asked that question
because we we have to direct help codes
that they must understand that we are in
charge and we must protect their
investment so yeah okay interesting
times they did Thank You counselor cute
now I'm just gonna go back to the
recommendations before I do I just want
to give thanks to the directors
obviously because this has been an
ongoing battle
I assume throughout this entire process
so thank you to them and of course to
our staff for getting this consultation
organized in a very short period of time
so we do appreciate that of you all um
I'm assuming that everybody is happy to
take the recommendations as well but I
will read through them so the council
recommends that the report be received
it with no consultation would commence
she is there the 19th of May and be
completed on Friday the 12th of June
that we zoom in the consuls preferred
option for investment and city block B
option one resulting in a total
investment of 46 million and approved
the consultation document extra money
for city clock now I just want to go
back to councilman a monster and very
quickly read the time frame were you
happy was there because I'm not sure it
was discussed yeah I don't think that
question was answered to be honest I
think we Annan was gonna answer it after
day yeah I can I just I did note that so
can I detect your victory in in to
answer that question and you know I'll
be happy to ask if anyone's happy to
move
it's the proposed timeframe for the
consultation is based on two factors
making sure that we're in line with the
legislative requirements this doesn't
require a special consultative procedure
but also to anoint enable you as counsel
to make a decision within the timeframe
that would be required by the developers
to commence development on their
required schedule at the beginning of
July so those are the reasons for the
timeframe and we feel that this is a you
know is a reasonable consultation period
because this there's no substantial
difference in the length of time of the
consultation no one we feel will be
disadvantaged and there's the option to
accept late entries if they do come in
but the dates are there because it's the
only way to meet the administrative
requirements in terms of putting the
agenda out enabling the hearings to take
place and enabling you to deliberate and
make your decision in June thank you in
our machine bringing a post in a current
covert world let's call it there are
still ability for everybody to be able
to consult or to enter submissions in
this environment yes there's option for
online submissions but there are also
options to pick up documents from the
service centers or request them to be
posted out and people can post their
submissions or drop them back great
thanks Rhiannon so with those
recommendations being read out is there
anyone happy to move those
recommendations to give that please
councillor Scout thank you anyone happy
to seek a nice Thank You councillor
Ludlow any other discussions or
questions on those items rally and all
those in favor please give me a wave
clear I'm hoping that you can count two
with me so sorry the only
his worshippers not showing us video but
otherwise I see everyone's participating
and you certainly have a majority thank
you worship can I clean your boat
pleasing you in favor I can I can't less
than the internet somewhere so I can
hear you alright okay we can see I'm
just asking you hippy with those
recommendations and favor or against
favor
thank you you worship so that's all of
us any weapon against motion carries
thank you very much I can't see you you
worship so you're working and can hear
you clearly
thank you I'm so we'll move to item
number seven which is the local
government funding agency document
changes in our last day but add yeah
Dave Auster to speak today thank you
thank you chew look this is very much a
procedural item basically the council
was aware that the LG FA are looking to
lend money directly to
ccos because we put an item up I think
it wasn't figure that it could be wrong
on the date which was effectively about
getting council to accept and and be
comfortable for Hogg Co to put in an
application to being loaned to for that
to occur there's a number of
consequential issues that need to happen
particularly in the documentation that
everybody who's signed up to be a member
of LG FA needs to go through and
effectively sign deeds which amend the
original deeds to make the leading to
see CE OS effective so this item is
really just to approve the three two
councils any two of listed in there and
three councils to take any two of to
sign that documentation to enable it to
happen I didn't include the
documentation there was around about 240
pages and I was quite technical legal
documentation it's been through
two sets of solicitors Andrews had a
review but I've had a review of it and
one of the solicitors doing it as
Russell McVeigh a act for the local
government funding agency and the other
one is Simpson Grierson & Simpson
grierson have been acting collectively
for the shareholders well we're not a
shareholder our interests are very much
aligned with the shareholders as a as a
land of the shareholders effectively
only we tend to facilitate the formation
of the company for the evening capacity
[Music]
and as procedures any questions around
there counselor ever and I was just
happy to move it Michael sorry okay I'm
happy to move that I would be happy to
seek in those recommendations and I take
it that day out or read that the local
government funding agency document
changes they received in the documents
be authorized to be signed by any two of
his worship the mere the DPD me in the
chair of Finance and Policy Committee so
all those in favor of those
recommendations please raise your right
hand against carriage thank you in our
final item on today's agenda is the
management governance in administration
administrative measures in Alec Jody
come I speak to their children I'm happy
to just take the reporters read again
this is just another procedural one to
just bring information forward tears
about the our genes use elections and
also that AGM the dates with the
rescheduled date sphere from July
Downton a goomba also they proposed
three mutts for consideration need to be
submitted by late July so I'm happy to
answer any questions you have any any
questions of Jody on this please Oh
lovely okay job well done
Jody up councillor so
I'm assuming she's gonna move those
recommendations but she may have a
question so I'll pass it to Leslie I'm
happy to move them but I've also just
got a comment which is just to ask
counsel if there would be interesting us
putting board agreement on the housing
issue we have previously discussed the
possibility of the government funding
which is only available to other
providers but not council providers and
I'm interested to know whether there
would be and Trustin in framing a remark
on that issue we obviously can't discuss
it today but I just was interested to
know whether we've just put in some work
in the leadership so because we can't
discuss today and I'm just mindful of
the time in our agenda can I just get a
we raise of hands as to who would be
comfortable to look at that so that can
be brought back to us if need be in the
next meeting 3 4 5 6 8 you have a
majority thank you clear Thank You
councillor Soper in with council
recommendations anyone happy to
synchronize recommendations on Jody's
report please thanks counselor Muenster
and all those in favor raise your right
hands against you wish it can I just ask
you were you and favor
I understood can you hear me all right a
nice weekend I understood that
abstention resilient for now and it's
under standing orders and it's never
called for and so you never sure he's
he's abstained and I've abstained on a
few issues and it's not recorded in the
minutes or anything I think of it as
part of the new regime of Standing
Orders we should give councillors that
option
yep fecal worship and I haven't called
that through this process nor have I
through any others if there's anyone who
wishes to it is the responsibility under
standing orders to advise so it would be
good chairmanship for me to call it from
now on and I'm happy to do that but just
if I - our elected members it is up to
you to advise if you wish to now I see
some people are shaking their heads and
summer coming so I'm assuming someone
disagrees
ma'am chair it be usual practice for the
chair to call for abstentions is my
point
oh sorry that was the point I was making
but I was going to be nice and do that
what I was trying to say wasn't it it's
up to individual elite de Menezes my
understanding to Razer correct do you
wish to raise one your worship Oh a lot
better now that because it was a couple
of resolutions back so that's all right
so long as it's noted in that and we all
agree it's the procedure that's fine
okay so just to clarify for his worship
and everybody else it isn't the cheese
responsibility to call for it it is
elected members who wish to raise that
so if we're all in agreeance a vet
process if you want to give me a we wave
that would be really helpful for me to
confirm that I am and following the
right process understanding orders thank
you
okay so moving on did we have a mover
and seconder and we've passed that
motion Lani can you just take me back
through that a little bit lost here yep
okay great thank you so there as far as
I'm aware counselors is the last part of
today's agenda in public and we will now
move into a public excluded is the any
other business before we do there great
nothing under urgent business that I
will move into public anyone happy to
seek in there happy sitting there Thank
You counsel
all those in favor I'll abstain from
moving into public square did you
worship yes
okay those against okay thank you and of
course a you'll note has worship for him
thank you Lani um Amit motions moved
that we move into public it's waited
thank you to anyone help there who's
watching for joining us this afternoon
for our meeting I wish you all well from
the Council of elected members and staff
so we will talk to you in the near
future
khaki tea and more I'll take your lead
henna so you can let me know when we are
able to move